what's up guys i'm ninja and we are
doing a wired autocomplete interview
let's get this over with we'll nail it
on the naked just rage now whatever
their whatever they're doing today is
ninja who is ninja twitch oh yeah I'm
just a streamer on Twitch that plays
video games man mainly for not right now
it isn't into dead uh yeah I'm actually
ninjas evil twin the other ninja died of
lignin unfortunately so isn't in just
streaming not right now but I usually am
about 10 hours a day so twitch.tv slash
ninja easy is ninja a hacker no it's all
natural talent I'm not a hacker why is
that actually what pops up is ninja an
athlete ooh that's a good one well I
mean technically I am an athlete because
I used to play soccer all the time for
like eating here's my life but if you're
talking about video games in general is
that an athlete do you guys I don't know
if we'll have our answer that uh that
controversy so a new card does ninja
know what marshmallow looks like this is
a good one dude so literally the first
time I ever met him he he had his mask
on and he had the marshmallow mascot and
then he ended up he took it off and it
was just a smaller version of the mask
and they took that one off and that
which is a smaller version of that mask
maybe he's just a marshmallow
she's got layers of marshmallows
underneath him does ninja have a wife I
do her name is Jessica her last name is
Blevins her alias is Jay ghosty and
she's also in the other room those ninja
play on PC I do I used to play an Xbox
Playstation all the other consoles
I was professional halo player for like
seven years but yes now I I'm at home on
the PC does ninja curse no bleep that
out of it no I didn't say it I believe
myself
oh no I do curse in public or we know
when I'm with my you know family and
friends not from my mom of course but
you know it's not you know excessive and
I don't do in front of kids does ninja
by tears what does that even mean
oh it's got to be the battle past the
four night battle past years I've done
for half the seasons hey I think I'm
done split it where I bought every
single tear out of the battle pass for
for night and I've also done it where I
just buy the battle pass bundle so
obviously by the battle pass up to level
25 and then I just earned the exp for
the rest of tiers so oh well we got a
lot of these do this is good okay more
does ninja so here we go does ninja Oh
God get paid by fortnight I have to
really think about this because I don't
miss my I don't think I've been paid by
them to do anything ever other than what
they've done for everyone which is the
support of creator code where you can
use code ninja and work code you know
whatever you know creator you want to
support in the and that's not you know
what I mean they didn't pay me for that
so no for tonight has not paid me
sadface does ninja speak Spanish hablo
poca español I took like five years of
Spanish when I was six years of Spanish
four years in high school two years in
college so I can understand most words
and I usually can pick up on
conversations as long as it's not that
crazy next level where like even the the
people speaking Spanish aren't even
finishing the sentences or the words
because they know what they're saying
and they're just like you know what you
don't have so you've been there you know
talking about doesn't engine use a
mechanical keyboard I do i use the
corsair k70 I'm not even sponsored by
them it's just a great keyboard the
rapid-fire keyboard and I love it so I
use good products man and that's one
does new job use a capture card I do use
a capture card i use an elgato capture
card an internal one external ones can
be tricky usually there's like latency
and stuff like that when you're
streaming with an external capture card
i don't really think anyone's really
nailed that yet so does ninja I think
that says work out does ninja work out
if you can't tell I'm sorry so no I do
not work out oh I like this one how long
has ninja mmm how long has the engine
been streaming I've been streaming for
about eight years
so I'm 27 I think I was 1920 when I
started shooting that's a good Google
search
how long is Ninja been playing for
tonight I'm playing since October of
last year so
about a year and like like 13 months how
long have you been married about one I
can give you the exact date definitely
more than a year it's like a year in
like four months right now I got me aust
12 best day ever by the way
how long has ninja been on YouTube so
I've been on YouTube for about five
years six years one of my original
accounts I actually deleted it on
accident I only had like I think 100,000
subs I didn't care about getting it back
because I just made a new one so I've
been on there for about five years I've
been uploading consistently for about a
year and a half how long has Ninja been
on Twitch I have been on Twitch since
literally day one I was on their
platform before they merged and actually
created twitch it was known as Justin
dot TV I was Justin dot TV forward slash
hyper ninja or ninjas hyper I believe
was what my name was on J TV I got the
original ninja and then I've you know
I've been partnered and ever since there
was the beta came out so forever
well what ninja what does ninja make in
a year
enough what did ninja I'm assuming this
is major in and in college I see it yeah
I literally was just getting my gen Ed's
I messed up my first year I went away to
college so I actually ended up blowing
like all the money that my grandparents
had saved up for me which is like twenty
thousand dollars my first two ition and
I was only doing gen Ed's which I could
have done that my second year I went to
a local college that's where I finished
my gen Ed's and it was way cheaper cuz I
never did anything crazy I never got
college credits in high school or
anything like that so yeah I didn't
major anything I was just just doing
getting my classes done get my Jenna to
go up to the next level of stuff what
does ninja eat on stream well that's a
great question what don't I eat on
stream was over eats man we live in a
really good area my wife and I so we
actually have a little bit everything we
got time Mexican Asian you know American
cuisine it's pretty much literally
anything and everything I eat so and
what is ninjas winrate it's really good
I mean I don't even know it but I know
that I have almost like 4,000 wins so I
think I actually have the most ones and
fortnight I love these and this is so
fun how did ninja meat drink this is
probably one of my favorite story to
tell my wife and I one day
we found out for my twitch stream to my
chat they were just like hey man
tracheas father you Jake responding
Instagram I didn't believe him we all
thought I was like you know a lie
I searched Drake on Instagram nothing
came up his name was champagne papi I
had no idea so yeah
looked it up he was following me I
followed him back and that was for much
it that's how that's how it all started
so how did ninja make so much money I
mean just twitch blew up with you know
fortnight and gaming and you know I was
there at the at the front of it I made
the decision to start streaming for a
night before a lot of other big
streamers did and my you know
personality and scale the game just kind
of took off viewers watched it I mean
that's how you know simple man ad
revenue stuff like that
how does ninja make his thumbnails super
simple so I start by no I don't make my
thumbnails we usually have artists who
create thumbnails and things like that
so we tell them you know what the what
the game is pretty much gonna be about
like the highlights things like that
they're gonna stick out because you know
your thumbnail is supposed to paint a
story for what happens in the game
that's how you get the best clicks on
your videos and things like that and we
don't like click baiting with our
thumbnails we like to you know just be
truthful so it's done pretty well so
farming 20 million subscribers in a year
well this is a long one don't ruin this
how many subscribers is them to have on
Twitch it's ever fluctuating the other
day I was at 60,000 and I haven't
streamed in like the last couple of days
so it dips down and yeah it's really
unfortunate when I'm not streaming I'm
losing subscribers that's literally what
happens with everyone on Twitch it sucks
how does ninja spend his money the only
thing that Jess and I really spent money
on is is like you know she buys a lot of
like Louis stuff which she uses every
single day like backpacks and and some
things for luggage and stuff like that I
have you know Louis shoes and Gucci
sweats and things like that but we don't
buy you know fancy cars we have a house
that we live in now which is you know
what we bought because it's perfect for
us we have to host people so we have
enough rooms for them but really man
it's all saved nice and tucked away
okay last card has ninja been on family
feud
yes I have funny story my wife and I a
girlfriend at a time we were just at her
inter Tosh tour we were watching a
family feud and I was like I love family
I love us so much people are so like
what are they doing these questions are
territory they're easy questions that he
answers are horrible is like my family
would kill this and then she's like why
don't you do it so I texted everyone who
I wanted to be in and they were like
yeah sure let's do it just and I ended
up driving down in Wisconsin we put a
video together uploaded YouTube
submitted it and they flew us out and
boom yeah we're on family feud we want
fast money twice I mean my brother has
never lost a game a lot yeah dude if you
guys watch my live stream every video I
upload to YouTube is a video that I win
but on my actual twitch stream twitch.tv
forward slash ninja
I'm live pretty much every day and I die
quite frequently whenever you're
dropping til two towers you're going for
high cut games or things like that
absolutely man you know it's a it's a
random game where you know there's a lot
of orangey people can you know shoot you
sniping in the back man it's unfortunate
it's unlucky you have bad days and good
days man everyone has bad days has ninja
been banned from fortnight I follow the
rules I don't sell my accounts and I
don't do stupid things that that is
against the Terms of Service so no I
have never been banned in fortnight and
I don't plan on it anytime soon this is
the last one man that's so much fun
has ninja moved house yes yes we've
actually moved three times in the last
like year and a half it's been terrible
no one ever want to move ever again but
yeah we have a beautiful beautiful home
now so guys thank you so much for all of
your questions that was so much fun and
I hope to be back you know sometime in
the future with a whole bunch of new
questions for you guys